the world's actually in a better place
than it was 50 years ago it's just that
the current conversation in America
because of the lack of Civility has us
all anxious the world is better today
than it's ever been in the history of
mankind yet so few people believe it I
think that happiness is remarkably quiet
and negativity is Extremely Loud so do
not allow that to confuse you of how
great things are the small minority of
people that are mad and angry and
hateful and dark are much louder than
the big percentage of us that are happy
and excited and feel great so I feel
like as somebody who's got full of
bright light and happiness then I need
to start getting louder about that as
well because that's the only way we're
going to come back
[Applause]